what seems to be this final stand now at
the azov style steel works
you can only imagine how terrifying it
must be for the civilians still trapped
there they've been sheltering there for
weeks now
but also for those brave you well for
those ukrainian defenders who have
bravely been holding out they have had
multiple chances being given to them by
the russian ministry of defense they the
russians have offered these so-called
ceasefires saying that they could come
out of the steel works but there is no
trust on either side the ukrainians have
refused to give up their positions they
know full well that they could well die
down there in these steel works the
ability to resupply them with weapons
with ammunition with of course food and
water is incredibly limited president
putin said to his forces he wanted to
besiege those steel works so that not
even a fly could get out and that was
two weeks ago now so you can only
imagine the conditions and yet they're
still fighting they haven't yet allowed
russian forces to push them out of those
steel works and while that remains for
russia it means they have to keep
concentrating firepower and manpower on
those steelworks and they cannot declare
a full capture of the city of mariopol
which has been a strategic aim since the
beginning of this war